hold on a second D AB bozos and homies
don't forget to pick up your tickets for
Town Hall in New York City May 9th it's
the biggest show we've ever done and we
want everybody there mix the standup
comedy plus you play a little a YG with
the crowd M we also have our card game
the round the second version of the card
game is on sale right now at arug
garbage.com it's over 50 of our
questions you get to play with your
friends your family call them trash it's
a fun game get involved arug garbage.com
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's new favorite
podcast this is R you gerage oh yeah
it's that a little show we sit down with
your favorite comedians and we find it
after they gr to be classy or they're
just a big old piece of trash TR trash
trash I'm your host a try coming at you
on a beautiful day we're out back here
with toies in the new edition she is
upstairs getting her New Year's
resolution list together okay I don't
know how anybody can drink any more than
she does but she's going to take a shot
at it in 2024 my co-host is coming at
you from across the table slightly
amused this week that was like uh that
was like reading a far side or something
I got a little chuckle at of you yeah
you're like the funny papers give it up
for KJ Kevin James Ryan what up gang
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rate view subscribe on
iTunes full available on YouTube as
those numbers are TR cook then obviously
the greatest website of all time
www.patreon.com you garbage go over
there like I don't know maybe at this
point four bajillion hours of content
good time and then also if you go over
there to
www.ar.com you can get tickets for our
brand new
announced New York City show at Town
Hall baby while supplies last all sales
are final let's go town hall to boys
stepping onto the great white way a big
one baby it's the biggest venue we've
ever played it's huge classy joint over
there real classy joint I don't know why
they want our filth in there but hey
buddy I'll go GNA be real nice Bob
Dylan couple other people hey Jimmy
Smiths he got Jimmy Smiths over there
yeah he did two nights there love
schmitts what's he just tell old stories
from NYPD Blue shout out to Smith about
Dennis Fran's lunches simple wits and
Schmidts need to do a [__] podcast
that thing be boom I'd be tuned in where
they just go over old episodes I love
that I'd love that Dennis fron retired
though yeah Vietnam vet Dennis fron
loved them showed showed his ass on that
show I remember I remember the first he
said dick one time oh my God man I was
like what this is ABC what are we doing
what the hell's going wrong with this
country how about a nice quick shout out
to our producer extraordinaire the old
magic man makes us all look good works
the ones the twos the threes and the
fours he crosses them tees and he dots
them eyes give it up for T-Bone MC
scruffs it's Toby McMullen everybody
what up boys what up T-Bones you you
didn't say historical venue acts such as
Bob Dylan have played you just said Bob
Dylan out of nowhere which is so had a
beer there one time he's like yeah we're
doing this amazing theater Bob Dylan he
played The Joint I know first time out
of the clubs is what they was his first
theater show they say there you go we'll
see it's our first big big big theater
show our very big theater show we're
very excited tickets are moving quick
I'd get them while they last you what I
mean you know speaking of uh New Year's
Eve M uh you know I'm not that big of a
fan sure yeah don't love it
sure I thought you well speaking of what
I mean you
didn't yeah you I I don't know I I don't
like that whole vibe of like it's you
know it's for amateurs I'm out there
doing it every night it's like yeah
whatever you can still party and put on
a hat and blow a streamer or whatever
sure or or your neighbor whatever you
want to do uh yeah traffic's real bed
yeah but it's a it's a party I also
drink a lot all the time H but it's like
for guys who look for an uh you know
let's get dressed up and get [__] up
and have some pigs in a blanket or
whatever I think you stay home and you
have you have some people over and do
you know do something like that they're
going out and stuff like that I'm not
saying go to [__] Time Square and sit
there like a psychopath I did it once it
was the worst [__] worst night of my
life stumbled in there trying to you
were trying to get a bag man we were in
Philly and uh they're like that's go up
it'll be fun and this kid I knew had an
apartment in Time Square so he was in
like the cut off sure man it sucked yeah
it like proper sucked yeah I would never
do that but the bar especially as like
your early 20s or whatever you go you P
you know it's like 200 bucks an open bar
some finger foods whatever whatever
that's a good time I was had a bad taste
in my mouth for cuz my mom hates hated
it when I was a kid mhm she didn't like
it fun family you guys are a good time I
think it's when she found out her mom
was dying or something like that J I
can't remember what it was so she always
hated New Year's Eve so we always stayed
in and uh
argued really screamed at each other we
always stayed in and uh my dad would
make like lobster or crabs or something
like that some some type of shellfish
and then we'd watch uh Greece and then
Dick Clark's rocking New Year's Eve sure
and then bang pots and pans at midnight
you got to do that little dirt bags out
there d d ding ding I remember the one
time I couldn't I was like real young I
couldn't stay up till midnight I did it
at like
6:15 neighbors were pissed thought the
British were
coming [__] we always got the broken
ones though she wouldn't let us use her
good pots and pans we always got broken
ones we always had a couple of broken
pots laying around for like water hand
no handle or whatever [__] burn the
[__] out of you I know remember getting
that dut she give us hot panss that Duty
as a kid to move that if you had like
dump the water out without the handle
man I was nervous for about 18 years
dumping that spaghetti when you were a
kid might as well been plutonium I know
really you up really [__] you up you a
New Year's Eve guy T-Bone
no thanks
pal no it's just not for me I don't like
I don't like Halloween you're not a
partyer anymore yeah you know it's it's
I feel like when I imagine when you go
back to high school and watch the high
school team play and I'm like ah I'd
love to get out there but it's not for
me anymore I don't go back and watch the
high school team play I don't do that
[__] he streams it
online I saw you out there you had your
letterman jacket on I'm in the booth
calling the game what are you talking
about [__] scotch in front of me got
my championship ring on
uhhuh now if my cousins was playing yeah
i' go see him but I wouldn't just go
back I don't go to like homecoming and
[__] like that I'm not a Fu weird you're
47 dude it'd be weird if you rolled up
stop remember me from the '90s they were
everybody was born in
2005 I left some old CDs in the locker
room if you guys I'm here to dig up to
Time
Capsule I told everybody I'd be back in
30 years where's Mahoney at he died man
everybody moved on and had family and
kids careers Let It Go I got my
shovel did you ever do that no time cap
I only that was to me that was a very
Trope you would see on uh TV shows like
Saved by the Bell F like all that kind
of [__] that was always an episode I
feel like we dug up one or we we planted
one when I was in like seventh or eighth
grade we got to go back and get it dude
if that's not a patreon video I don't
know what is I did you dig it up I don't
know where it is the school did it I
think my middle school did it uhhuh I
don't think I got to put anything in
there yeah probably not probably Steve
rumaging through it they caught you
Henry that's my
candy yeah uh no we've never did it I
never understood that I didn't learn
about it till later it seems weird like
I don't know what you expect when you do
if thousands of years that would be cool
well then what's the payoff that's what
I'm saying you like I'm not going to
bury something and dig it up in 15 years
yeah oh this is what soda cans looked
like back then what do you put in there
I don't know books yeah why that's what
I'm saying I don't understand I don't
understand the whole uh the pay I don't
know what to pay off you have a
reasoning behind that why they do time
capsules cuz it's fun is it you two
don't like [__] New Year's Eve but
you're doing time capsules I don't like
time capsules who doesn't want an
original 1995 copy of the Blue Bell
Penny Saver man come on it's good time
that would have been I look at I think
about that all the time all the toys and
[__] that I had when I was a kid if I
just would have kept one in the
packaging oh maybe you're not supposed
to dig them up but time capsule is
historic cach of goods or information
usually intended as a deliberate method
of Comm communication with future people
whoa and help future archaeologists
anthropologists or historians we should
do one damn let's do a time capsule
where I don't know we'll put it
somewhere okay all right I'm in and then
we'll leave uh we'll do a well this is
essentially a Time caps this is going to
live forever what do you mean until
there's a solar flare that takes out the
internet sure oh damn what are you guys
smoking what the [__] the hell kind of
episode is this I like the way you think
okay yeah I'll do one I never thought
about it oh you know what we should do
we should do like a bar treasure and
come up with a map and see if anybody
can find it how much cash are we talking
I don't know 10 grand I'll take a look
in there 10 we say it's 10 grand
somebody finds it eight eight bucks in
there how the [__] did you find it did
you play that Pokemon [__] when it came
out Pokémon go on the phone oh I was out
there baby were you I was cat I was
catching them all that was not too long
ago without question that was like 5
Years Ago Toby really yeah man must have
been beating him away with a stick huh
that's crazy Jesus that was nuts you'd
see people in like in like Central Park
just disappearing in the shadows people
like running into churches and ruining
weddings and masses and stuff like cuz
people like I got to get Charizard or
whatever what was it what was exactly I
don't really understand what Pokemon was
they were in eggs right no that's more
of a tomag got I think you're thinking
shout out to the you don't know tomag
got tomag got tamagachi tamag tamagachi
egg sounds like a third like a little
key they just gave him 700
million uh they were like little eggs it
was just like a little video game uh and
there was this guy that lived there you
had to feed him he pooped you had to
like clean up you had to keep him alive
yeah and I don't know I mean but at the
time that technology was nuts okay and
you just had a like wait hold on was it
a toy or a video game a toy it was like
this big but it was a video a little
video game oh I know what you're talking
about it was like a keychain you would
like you know whatever and you had to
like feed them whatever all this
different stuff and how long you could
live and you'd be like Oh I'm 33 days
and if you didn't shower them or
whatever he you know I don't know
[__] killed himself or whatever no
[__] um we did that when I was a kid we
didn't do it but other other schools did
it with like chickens yeah that was
another to me that was another big thing
on [__] sitcoms they would have like
the home class and they'd be like hey
you have to you'd have to take care of
this pound of sugar or this watermelon
or like whatever it was and they always
like lost it or fell in love with it and
then found it again yeah my cousin went
to school that was there was they they
sent him home with an actual chicken
like an egg that how do he go to school
I don't know somewhere out on the Range
godamn in the sticks that's wild but it
was in like a little like a Geral cage
with a with like a heat lamp over it
yeah yeah um I think his dad atte it to
be honest with
you chicken omelets coming up gang a
couple of
scrambies can't make a scramby scrambled
egg out of a chick why not you need an
EG you need an egg oh it's fertilized
what huh well they gave him an egg or an
actual chick no they gave him an egg
with a chick inside and he had a I
thought I thought you thought omelets
were made of actual live chickens um no
did you have to do the frog or anything
dissect we did a pig I think a pig
uh-huh what the [__] a baby pig Jesus
uh-huh you did pork bellies get that bun
of burner
going I was doing Habachi out
there uh we did do the Frog um I don't
really remember it too well it wasn't we
didn't have to kill it it was already
dead I know what I thought you had to
kill it no they come in a bag I'm not
you think I put them in a [__] this
pig in a headlock and took them out no I
remember they were like you have to do
this I'm like this is like Lord of The
Fly [__] what are we doing here so I
remember that from alah high smell dude
right before lunch yikes I didn't get it
either what the [__] does the frog have
to do with me it's supposed to teach me
about Anatomy I'm not a
frog well you know what I mean sure you
got to look at all the different [__]
and stuff I don't think I either I think
I did it but I didn't do it well I think
I just like cut it open and left it
there something we also had to do an owl
pellet an owl pellet uh what does that
mean they uh an owl large birds of prey
they eat the whole thing right they'll
eat like a whole bird or something okay
and then their stomach digest everything
they can digest but it can't digest the
bone so it spits this like egg pellet
back up it's like the size of a
tamagachi egg uh and then you have to
like dig through it and put the bones
together to find out what
uh [__] what kind of roadkill education
is this dude that's good
eatting now when you're hitting a deer
on the highway you just want to graze it
it's the
hoof what yeah your science class
happened on the side of I95 this was
lunch what you guys talking about was it
an egg that they coughed up no it's like
imagine like a dry like a placea or uh
placenta yeah placea um imagine like an
egg shaped thing yeah with like it was
like Dy dirt kind of and there was like
feathers and Bones in there and you have
to like go like all right this is a beak
this is a vertebrae and the owl would so
the ow eats a
bird all the doesn't can't I'm not Jack
Han over here I don't have all the
[__] can't digest the bones and it
spits that stuff up yeah and then you go
like oh you know for lunch you had a
[__] whatever Jesus how'd you get the
owl I I think they sell the they sell
the pellets they're called pellets owl P
Toby can you get something on this Jesus
that's [__] vicious frog I get but
they weren't killing owls were they no
this is they just I guess like an owl
Farm or something or whatever I don't
know where they're getting these things
why you put listen I didn't come up with
the experiment did you figure it out
what he ate yeah he had like a he had
like ay-
old I think it was a big
man it was a number two chicken tender
man I see couple of sesame seeds in
there um they just called owl pellets
yeah really see if they're still doing
it in school they can't be why not
people would freak out dude this was
like
2001 like this wasn't that Longo changed
guess 22 years holy
[__] yeah is the mass of an undigested
parts of a bird's food that come from
bird species occasionally
regurgitate yeah it includes the
exoskeleton of insects indigestible
plants the exoskeleton matter bones fur
bills Claws and teeth I'm telling you
man it was wild teeth the [__] that Al's
eating yeah what the [__] an Al eating
that has teeth teeth uh squirrel maybe
yeah yeah oh yeah there you go they [__]
you up man Birds of Prey scare your boy
yeah they're scary I think it's much
rare now to do this the most recent I'm
seeing is someone did it in 2015 okay
probably a bunch of Hill you weren't
cutting up frogs up there at that uh
hippie School you went to right we were
rolling fatties and blowing clouds
[__] making tie-dye t-shirts and [__]
for it was Cloud your neighbor
what
um yeah that was the only really weird
thing we did we didn't have we didn't
have like home we had like one home we
didn't have like pep rallies all that
like [__] Saved by the Bell you
didn't do that [__] we had like one pep
rally a year we had homecomings we had a
pep rally where we did a bonfire I think
they yeah that was like real I think
they 86ed it yeah that was that that
[__] all got [__] stopped before yeah
some [__] idiot some dumbass [__]
Falls in it or something like that that
[__] was cool was cool a bunch of cars
parked in a circle with the headlights
pointed in I wanted to do that man that
and a keger in the woods you never did a
keg in the woods oh we always had like
basement and [__] there like someone's
parents were out of town keg in the
woods was all right also I'm not lugging
a [__] keg back in the woods get a
sixer it's B yob at that point what are
you doing my fat ass [__] stuck in
Thorn bushes meet me at the moon tower
uh yeah we never uh we were never big
cake guys we were cases of beer yeah we
never really keg keg is a pain in the
ass they are then you got a keg and
you're like that's rolling around in
your trunk and like you know that that
ain't easily maneuverable for someone's
parents were out of town we would get
kegs it took a skill to tap one too to
tap it and get it nice you're talking to
a guy who could tap a okay is that right
yeah look at you freshman year of
college real bit who's ta I'll tap it we
got the K you don't know a t I had my
own tap pull it out like a holster you
did Bing we had a party house he had to
have one they were harder to come by
than the they were they you got to tap
you get the who's got to cuz they were
like you you had to pay like 50 60 bucks
to rent those from the guy yeah K but
talking about rocket money rocket money
do you know what that is no please tell
me I have no clue what it is I'm going
to tell you rocket money is a personal
finance app that finds and cancels your
unwanted subscriptions monitors your
spending and helps you lower your bills
all in one place how about that it's
awesome I can see my subscriptions I got
it all right there if I don't want
something Bing it's gone don't realize I
had it they tell you yo you've been
getting banged out by these people for
the last year Bing it's gone it's
fantastic I used it I found out I was
subscribed to dildo with a month club I
was like I didn't sign up for this
someone's been playing around on my card
boom canceled it now it's more money in
my pocket at the end of the month you
nobody uh they'll never try to get uh
they'll even try to get you a refund for
months of wasted money negotiate lower
bills by up to 20% all you have to do is
take a picture of your bill and Rocket
money takes care of the rest here is the
turkey rocket money has over 5 million
users and has helped save its member an
average of $720 a year with over $500
million in cancel subscription shout out
to it that's some cash stop wasting
money on things you don't use cancel
your unwanted subscriptions by to Rocket
money.com garbage that's rocket
money.com garbage rocket money.com
garbage do it okay we're talking about
Beam Beam Me Up Daddyo little too much
dreaming about sugar plums and uh pixie
fairies or whatever it is there pork
chop waking me up you've been deep into
the sugar let me tell you something gang
do yourself a favor and get on beam with
a hot chocolate that knocks you right
out and put you to sleep you wake up
feeling rested you wake up feeling
refreshed and you're ready to take on
the day just just mix a scoop with hot
water or milk Stir It Up and wait for
the magic to happen with Nano CBD and
all natural ingredients beam will have
you in
Dreamland in no time I like that baby uh
it's fantastic they sent us some uh I
did it here man I had I had to Tak an
Uber home I was it got me falling all
over the dance floor it got me drowsy
all jokes aside uh it's a fantastic
product it's available delicious flavors
like chocolate peanut butter aim Machi
cinnamon cocoa and sea salt caramel beam
only has 15 calories and 0 g of sugar
today areu garbage listeners get a
special discount on beams dream powder
they're bestselling healthy hot cocoa
for sleep with no added sugar better
sleep has never tasted better the
numbers don't lie in a clinical study 93
of participants reported dream helped
them get better sleep if you want to try
beam's bestselling dream powder get up
to 40% off for a limited time when you
go to shop beam.com garbage and use the
code garbage at check out that shop beam
bam.com garbage and use the code garbage
for 40% off do it party ball was big
Kors light party ball never did that I
remember I remember those at like at
barbecues and [__] as a kid like
probably when you were 18 I was 10 or
whatever you know parents those they
start floating in the ice and [__] once
they got empty once you're done with
that thing that goes right in the trash
night never knew about what they still
do those Coors Light party balls debone
I thought it was Bud Light No was Coors
Light it was before my drinking days
I've never seen the these look like
tanks of nitrous the party balls they're
sick yeah dude they were awesome what
dude they were
awesome pick one of them up ice it down
[__] screaming cold it's like a
cooler version of the hinin pony keg oh
that thing sucks I always thought there
was candy in that what I thought it was
like fake I thought it was just for
decoration that sucked that was too
little AB booze my boy Vinnie we would
go buy a bunch of those and then Vinnie
with the skinny would get that for him
and just like roll around a party with a
[__] with a little mini geg doing
like doing inverted G stands and stuff
man ah it's all right any new technology
that came out with booze or different
technology we went real hard in on I
remember we found a place that sold the
ponies the little the little beers man
you couldn't tell us [__] the pony my
biggest regret in ending my drinking
career is that I did it right as people
really dialed in the tornado with the B
that looks so cool so awesome I haven't
done that oh it's so tight I'm not
chugging beers anymore you know I'm I'm
an endurance man we had ponies not that
long ago yeah uh Buffalo Bar and buffalo
with the with the hot dogs that they
were the High Life ones and they they're
cool cuz they look like mini 40s so do
the Miller Light ones they're not like
the Rolling Rock ones are different you
know they're little bangers yeah same
with the corona ones the rolling rocks
just like like me bottle the Miller ones
are like tiny little 40s feel real cool
[__] feel like King Kong be all right
anyway M Let's uh let's get to some cues
here yeah all that aside gang we got a
God darn Family episode when you sign up
on the greatest website of all time
already on patreon you get to submit a
question we'll answer your garbage
question on the air that's how we do it
around here M this one's from Wyatt uh
hey there $10 investor never had one
read do you know anyone that calls it an
optional illusion
that's pretty
bad I choose not to
participate it's
optional it's not a mandatory illusion
that just makes me think of those things
that you would stare at I never I never
got one of them I got it once the 3D art
I got it once magic ey oh I got it once
and it was like I was like what the [__]
it was a space shuttle with some planets
behind it and then I could never do it
after that I've never dude I remember
staring at this one close far crossing
my eyes not crossing my focus not F I
couldn't and a when everybody else
around you gets it you start you start
panicking and you're like concentrating
too much how do you not look at it but
look at it that's what people would tell
me you got to look at it but not look at
it it's like what the [__] I'm high as
[__] over here I'm on [__] moon rocks
I was real young too I was like seven or
eight I never I never [__] got those
things were hot did you have own one no
way my my my mom was bringing that that
devil that black magic into the house
that's Voodoo [__] I want paintings I
can see yeah get the [__] out of here I
can see a young Hank Foley really lying
about seeing it uhhuh oh what holy [__]
yeah it's bigger than I thought that's
cool as [__] no way [__] out of
here make with the chicken fingers right
you you're doing that thing where people
are like oh what is it oh you you tell
me what you see why don't you you tell
me no you always knew there was only a
couple of them it was either a ship or a
shuttle or something like that there was
only a few of them as far as I knew I
think I only really ever saw two of them
ever in my life and I never I never got
them one was definitely a space shut
there probably more than a couple I
would assume you need a real solid cuz
it's got to be a solid shape that you
can pick out based on the outline sure
cuz it's not like it has depth or
anything just kind of separates I still
don't can you see them now like can you
show me can I Google what it looks like
you can't do it now oh yeah of what the
image is you wouldn't be able to do it
on a computer no but like can you show
me we have to have some sort of
Technology where they I don't even know
what it looks like you know what I mean
looks like a space shuttle flying in
between planets yeah but all like with
yeah it's just all the same color though
right no it's pretty well defined really
I only saw it
once I don't the more you talk the more
I think you you didn't see it yes I did
nuh Toby you got it uh I'm I'm not
seeing any ones that'll show you the
image but I was trying to that's how
they get you they want you to spend the
money and buy it not giving that [__]
away for free money talks dude yeah what
are you nuts oh wait no I did find one
space Shadow uh Eagle Eagle oo USA us I
didn't see
it the hell can you text it to me uh yes
thanks oh I'm d one time we like this
well well documented we were never like
a big intellectual game that kind of
thing cool cool new art we were never
big on puzzles or anything more of a big
b Bill big Billy Bass family did I tell
you I I this show was happening and I
went home it probably like two years ago
or you know a year ago and we have a
knockoff one that like someone made it's
not even a real one dude it was it was I
think myep step dad was like I ain't
paying for that marketing you know what
I mean what's that a mackerel he's like
Steve make some or whatever it was on a
two like a 2x4 it's a dead
flounder thing starts sticking up the
garage is that hit um but my my brother
one time I think for Christmas or
something or birthday his birthday was
right by Christmas so and was like right
around now he got a [__] a three this
is when like that [__] they started
pushing that kind of Technology onto
like consumer goods it was a 3D Puzzle
kind of turned into like it was like a
supposed to be like a skyscraper or like
an apartment I know what you're talking
about and we could never figure it out
dude we got we got it like four stories
high it looked like Iraq it just looked
like something it looked like a drone
came in and took out a [__] city
block it was bad it never got done oh
man when you couldn't do something as a
family you felt like a real loser sure I
remember me and my dad being in 7-Eleven
for about an hour trying to figure out
the soda
machine no for it says push for a while
7-Eleven the 7-Eleven near us had a
movie vending machine this was cassette
tapes or VH movie vending machine a
movie vending machine is similar to that
but this looked like a big candy vending
machine with movies in it and if
something was wrong with the Blockbuster
your dad shaking it going give me dop
gun I just want and a Crunch bar we own
Top Gun
[__] hey it's up there
um if there was something wrong or fishy
with the Blockbuster or the West Coast
like if there was you were a West Coast
Video fan I worked a West Coast video oh
[__] I yeah we were a West Coast Video
senior year of high school work there uh
used to take a peruse in the back and it
was this couple owned it and I'm pretty
sure they were swinging it was this
older dude with this smoke show wife man
used to have to work with her smell of
popcorn and Twizzlers gets me going
these days used to love the way that
place you remember being that young and
like the hot girl at work who was like a
little older or whatever man I worked at
a golf course and this this girl was
there was two there was the bartender at
the golf course who's always a smoke
show or the beverage car girl shout out
do you and this other girl that worked
with me her dad owned it and like they
made her work for the summer and
man dude I'd come in and like a dirty
[__] shirt hi thanks for calling
Stinger City this is Kevin speaking how
can I help you reporting for
Duty she was this rich girl man I
brought the little fell with you huh I
would pull up in like dirty cargo shorts
and like up yeah and like I pull up in
my Chevy Lumina with the paint peeling
off of it man I didn't she was driving
like a Jag or something I didn't stand
the CH I'd pull up and see what she was
working like [__] I should have showered
today I guess I'm not getting lunch that
would have looked like a loser yeah I'm
meeting three hot dogs in front of
her I used to crush diesels at that job
you got a boyfriend or
what but no me and my if there was
anything wrong same [__] like STI
Hawkins dates is coming
up what was in your Al
pellet you want to do a time capsule
sometime um if there was anything fishy
with the Blockbuster card or the West
Coast card or like you owed money on it
or something you mean yeah and it still
hadn't been properly the case was still
pending like my mom hadn't figured out
hopefully you guys are going to West
Coast Video
Court I'm on probation goddamn it I
think we walked from West Coast Video
she just dipped on that but she would if
if she hadn't figured out whose fault it
was and put the screws in them she'd pay
it but there there was due process you
had to figure out who cause a stink yeah
she was causing a stink and we got
jammed up one time we went to
Blockbuster and it was like you guys owe
like 50 bucks [__] out of here I'm not
paying that I'm want to go fight this
vending machine at 7-Eleven so we went
up there and literally for like an hour
we're just throwing chili dogs at it
we're in like just like a they don't
waste a good CD it was in like a regular
aisle like where like the candy was and
we're in there for like an hour like I
want to there what do you want I
couldn't figure out what I wanted and
then he we go to [__] do it and it's
like he we couldn't figure out how to
get it out of there we couldn't figure
out how to put the money in and the guyy
like I don't know they put that in a
third party I don't know yeah it's like
the ATM machine it was brutal cuz I
remember my neighbor's mom came in and
she was like what the [__] are you guys
doing we're like all we're looking for a
movie she's like all right felt like an
idiot the only time I ever used one of
those I was on vacation with my family
VHS vending machine in the hotel lobby I
got scream so psyched threw it on and my
family came home right as it started and
my mom was like what is this oh my God
right as Drew Barry Moore is getting it
you know made me go downstairs and swap
it out for Spice World no what spice
world the Spice Girls movie Jesus man
that's so your dad
wanted now go to bed
Toby should grab strip teas while you're
down here spice up your life you think
on show Girls
huh
um I I never we were never that was
never a thing of like not allowed to
watch a movie or they would just send us
out we I it was like whatever my parents
really I mean like I I mean we weren't
watching porn at the house violence was
okay anything sexual we would just say
get get in the living room or you know
get get in the hallway I still knew what
was going on now that's how you make a
real Pur
yeah yeah get back there and peek like a
normal
kid smash your wiener on the back of the
couch uh I remember one time it was uh I
mean like not like whatever like we
didn't have HBO we didn't have any
premium CH we didn't have anything at my
mom's house just basic cable and then my
dad had HBO and I remember one time it
was like you know probably I was you
know 10 or 11 it was like a Saturday
night I didn't go out or whatever we're
just like sitting there watching TV and
he's flipping through the you and your
hot dogss this was pre guide you know
what I mean like you're just clunking
through channels and it was when they
were like slower too my Dad loved that
it had to like oh I still do it yeah it
had to like land on a channel you see it
like the the technology wasn't
like and man they got they it's me and
my dad and he [__] hits uh he goes to
[__] I guess we land on HBO and it's
some guy laying in bed it's like a you
know a real sex it was like a movie or
maybe was show Cinemax or something and
it's this girl tugging this dude dude
he's fully naked and she's like see his
wiener yeah just that wasn't HBO might
have been
spice no it was it had to be Cinema he
yeah it didn't show dick in that no
dude you were watching Playgirl TV dude
if trust me if we had it I would have
[__] known there's no way it wasn't
Cinemax or you didn't see penis there's
no way cinem Cinemax and HB weren't
showing noodle I'm pretty sure dude it
had to be I don't know what to tell you
or maybe it was like a regular movie and
that was like and it definitely was a
red shoe D it wasn't dgy getting whacked
off red shoe D getting jerked off by
[Laughter]
Scully did HBO show penis no never
believe yeah here's the HBO's 25y year
obsession with penis really yeah it
might have just been a part of like a
regular movie that had that scene in it
I don't know it wasn't like you know
there was no music playing in the
background or anything uh man a hand job
scene in a movie is wild man I know your
dad saying [__] like nobody likes
that yeah holy [__] yeah HBO's long
history of full frontal penis from real
sex to Game of
Thrones yeah I'm telling you what your
dad cuz that was the only thing we ever
had I think what' your dad do started
jerking
on no I think he like you know what I or
I think it was just dead silence and we
were just like we were both kind of like
you know man he this channel better
hurry up so we can move on and act like
this never happened
yikes oh God that's [__] great that's
a tough look um all right let's see here
this is from ooal Rules uh is a garbage
have a mechanical bull at your wedding
reception whoa God you're from Texas or
something country sure I'll give you
that from a big country I'll give you
that that would be fun and if it's not
like a formal formal if it's more of
like a party type thing I'd get that and
you're a couple of you know ranchers my
mom just went to a wedding in Texas oh
Jesus Christ [__] up there did you
ever see uh break a hip no but the
photos everyone it is a more cash sure
nice jeans and a [__] pair of uh
cowboy boots and like a well that's
dressing up for a cowboy a jacket bolo
tie with a nice
mhm um look pretty sweet that's uh I
mean to
me a mechanical bull is very
erotic really it's not yeah that's why
the bars have them oh like yeah the
chick's still what do you mean the chick
[__] humping a a big bull you know
what I mean uh yeah why do you think
they crank it to 11 when a guy gets on
yeah get the [__] out of here what I was
thinking launch him across the room
let's get sh back up here and [__]
shake her tip see the whale tail I never
thought about that yeah and then like
they like tilt it and then like sh yeah
it's like it's all it's just some
hornball back there with a joystick
wailing on himself like
HBO uh yeah so I mean if you to me if
you had one of those at a wedding people
be [__] hooking up left and right
that's not bad you get all drunk it's
like I no one's doing that sober that's
like you're drunk and then you're all
there's just a bunch of dudes uh you
know I thought it always was to try to
get you off I didn't even think about
that it is if you're thinking about it e
i mechanical bull in a wedding dress is
a Next Level tough look
mhm yeah yeah you figure if you have one
of those you're changing a lot of those
broads they change now they take the
Gown off and put something comfortable
on don't they I don't think so I'm not
saying it doesn't happen but like I mean
most weddings the girls I mean I think I
thought you had like the the gown for
the C ceremony and then a reception
thing you go put on like some sweats or
something or whatever or like a I don't
know a cocktail dress I don't think so I
mean I I don't know uh I don't think
I've ever seen that I think those girls
are very uh adamant about their dress
and looking good in their dress and
showing it off you know I bet you
there's for sure a situation where it's
like the zipper pants where they zipped
into shorts where you could like Zip off
a section to yeah yeah I'm sure but I
mean I think as most I don't know
everybody and I've been to no one's ever
changed into sweats as you called not
sweats sweats was a bit just ripping her
dress off like like her warm-up
pants starting center hopping on the
cian yeah see that the Bull's very
sibian
esque man remember the first time I saw
that thing AI Mai I think it was Stern
and I was like where did they make this
thing custom dude I remember I can tell
you exactly when it was it was [__]
1991 I was in the back of my brother's
car there was like four four of us in
the car driving the [__] school and
he had somebody on talking about this
and that like some stripper or porn star
or something like that and when Howard
used to get he'd get into that voice and
be like then what you doing that dude
the four of us just not saying a word
just rock [__] hard just [__]
jumped up dude driving to school
something else when you walking in a
walking into a school with a loaded gun
I know when you couldn't get access that
as easily as you can now when you came
across it it was so you know it was
unbelievable sultry what it did to you
the level of hormones that were being
pumped through your body I know nuts I
remember watching Stern on when it was
on TV and it was everything would be
blurred and stuff like that and I'd be
like oh my God what's going on and then
the channel 9 show uh I don't remember
on HBO that one or on demand he it was
on demand on like HBO or whatever all
right or Showtime or something but I
remember it would be all blurred
pixelated and I'd be like a what's going
on and it cut to his big nose and i' be
like get out of here Howard
I man yeah I said I've seen a girl I
went to high school with was on it got
topless as a Playboy contest and I mean
when we found that out it was I sped
over to my buddy's
house to catch that how wait she was in
high school we were just out of high
school I think it was summer going yeah
not in high school it was summer going
into freshman year or maybe just after
fresh it was an 18 or 19 yeah anytime
you did stuff like that you and the
other two she was up with two uggos yeah
yeah and I'm like this is I'm like this
is set up for her to win yeah it was she
win yeah really yeah was that she was a
playmate for a long time a playmate
there a girl had dinner with me and my
family and within 10 minutes was telling
my parents how she had Jello wrestled on
Jerry Springer jeez wait was this a girl
you were dating no it was just a homie a
friend of yours yeah keep a Tight Crew
huh what yeah dude Scholars an artist
huh it was bad she was staying with us
for like four days too she volunteer
that information because I ran around
with thieves and scall why was she
staying why was she staying with you
what's up why was she staying with you I
love what's up when he for sure heard
the question what' you say have a match
in
town this just during the jelly shortage
at
08 uh no she was visiting we were we
were in in Scotland at the time she came
to she came to hang jeez yeah bad luck
yeah I doubt your mother appreciated
that well she was more upset that she
didn't eat any of her food than she
cooked just imagine your mom cut oh so
you all have a dirty
[__] oh Toby didn't mention you were a
dumb [__]
filthy [__] I think oh
man she can't she had dinner and didn't
eat yeah I would have [__] lost it
too she was cutting weight for the
match you know how going to goes big guy
yeah i' been there sister three more
pounds all waterweight I'd have been
pissed too it wasn't great my cousin
brought a friend to Thanksgiving one
time I think I told you and she got
there and went up and took a nap what my
uncle was like what the [__] is this
just brought out of my house and then
came down after Grace like halfway
through the meal like all sleepy and
like got like a little bit of mashed
potatoes and some turkey oh
[__] never saw her again get
out all right what the [__] you staring
at me for I was agreeing with you I was
agreeing with your
mother I was trashing you I was agreeing
with your mom I was just
listening uh all right let's see here
this is from the head homie uh are you
garbage are you garbage if you've ever
been told you know how much underwater
welders
make every dirt bag knows that you know
how much they make and then it's always
way over $14 million an hour them and
the guys that uh change the bulbs on the
Transformers oh yeah yeah yeah that kind
of [__] they make it seem like it's an
hour and you get $8 million which it's
good money that's like that one there
was like that that clip going around
that guy has to climb like that crazy
high sat or antenna and he's like got to
do it once a year and he makes some
crazy amount of money to do it or that's
why we all this is before it's $600,000
a year yeah to do as an underwater
welder no to change the light to change
those light bulbs on those cranes or
those Towers 600 Grand a year it takes
you like six hours to climb it and it's
crazy dangerous yeah you're hooked up
though can you see what an underwater
welder makes also I believe that is one
of the very dangerous jobs an underwater
welder you think that shit's brutal yeah
those guys that go down there in the
dark and can't see [__] get the [__] out
of here what do you got T $22 an hour
get out of
here is that just one of those dirt bag
Blue Collar myths yeah no [__] well
that's why it's an underwater welder in
New York City Dam that's got to be the
highest rate too in the [__] Hudson
this is before uh to catch a no uh what
Deadliest Catch sorry without the crabs
this is before Deadliest Catch when I
was in high school we floated the idea
of going up to Alaska and work on a and
work on a crabbing boat cuz they said
you can make so much money sure but it
was so dangerous well what's his name
Soder went up there like a canery or
something right yeah mhm those dudes are
I mean I loved that show I'll still
watch that show I was like all about
that [__] show uh yeah it's a rough
you have to be a certain kind of [__]
detached from reality go to Alaska and
then get on a boat and go even [__]
further out you know what I mean that's
a c that's a guy running from something
that kind of guy and oil rig guys sure
that's a thing I never understood howo
it's cool it it's got kind of a
firefighter Vibe cuz you're like out
there eating stew with your boys or
whatever firefighter with a record what
do they call them hard hats hard
something rough necks rough necks oh
that's cool it's pretty sick real those
guys get laate couple of rough necks
rough necks uh what are those things
then the government might ask you to
save the world yeah again shoot you to
space that b affle clip that's going
around of him going up to JJ Abrams
direct that movie no uh Michael Bay
Michael Bay go to Michael Bay and be
like why is it easier to train drill
guys to be astronauts than astronauts to
drill and he was like get the [__] out
of my face oh what on the set on the set
they're like halfway through the movie
well that's like the biggest flaw of
that movie
yeah said they they shoot Steve Bui into
space to save the
day man that's I don't care who you are
that was a [__] home
run man that'll get me that'll still get
me to tear up oh I'll dude I'm always
crying at the end of that Affleck and
Willis Harry W Liv
Tyler love a live Tyler hello loved her
in uh Lord of the Rings too great
princess Empire Records never saw it
really
no got your back for staring at yeah
that's probably his favorite movie I was
listening to watch in the West Coast all
the time just trash you just to trash of
this guy talk about a [__] throw you
front of the bus what are those I want
to I don't never understood what are
those things that are are they oil rigs
like the Platforms in the water yeah is
that then people live on those yeah no
that that's insane that's the thing that
in the Gulf didn't that blow up in or
was that that's in the Gulf I no that
was a pipeline wasn't that was just a
pipeline I don't know I'm not up on
Karen events from 20 years ago yeah
they're oil rigs they're deep water they
SLE yeah that deep water [__] the deep
water Horizon whoa is that a real name
the movie uh vent Horizon is the movie
you're thinking of okay what was that
thing down there I forget was like an
alien or something we got two things
going all right kiy Event Horizon
py what were we asking
what was the thing in Event Horizon the
it was the spaceship that went to hell
that went to hell yeah huh amazing movie
for two acts really falls apart in the
third yeah I liked it rough neck still
the same thing 23 an hour I guess I I
think those guys you don't spend any of
the money though you can get that job on
zip recruiter yikes uh I guess that job
is like yeah you go there for two months
or it's like that long those like that
shift work and you don't spend any money
you don't spend any money while you're
out there and then you're you're also
probably you're based in Texas or
something or Louisiana like something
that's not probably wailing on yourself
out there oh could you imagine just pin
up [__] calendars [__] leave me
home for a day I get get after
it uh um the only reason I know about
those things is because GI Joe had one
of
those it oil rig yeah it was it was a
base it was a bass but it was shaped
like one of those that's where my
interest my curiosity in those game as a
Young Man I feel that they're they're
not I feel like I think they're they're
anchored too like like some of them
aren't it's not like they're not on
stilts that go to the it reminds me of
Deep Blue Sea and I don't like it oh
yeah yeah sharks swim backwards no one
likes that man oh man [__] that deep
blue c you never seen that is L Cool J
in that yeah yeah he's the chef or the
cook he's the cook yeah I've seen that
man that one will [__] freak me out
it's like born identity was Shar
those guys are it's Jason
B man those sh yeah those sharks learn
and then they yeah I didn't I didn't
like that oh yeah that's right they
start like putting like Plasma in their
head to make them smarter right yeah
never [__] with them using guns and
[__] smoking eaters where you at come
out I know you're in
there we got your family out here you
live at 1 two three Main
Street I could I could never do H none
of that [__] I I would Panic at being
out there alone that was even with the
cruise ship I was having panic like I I
thought that first hour on the cruise of
like I'm just out here stuck out here
jammed up freaks me out so like living
in that kind of thing I take a while for
a chopper to get out there and get you
then getting getting raised off the
thing I'm the guy I'd rather go down
with the ship than be in that basket
hanging out spinning or whatever they
just did that somewhere where they
pulled like 53 people out of the water
and it took them like hours I would
[__] freak out waiting for that not
for plus they probably wouldn't be able
to take
me yeah those things have to get two
Choppers no I think like a a a coast
guard Black hop helicopter could lift me
out of the
water I but pull it down no you'd
probably be fine they charged me for it
God damn it helicopters lift like 50 ton
[__] like air conditioning units in
sure yeah one of those crane ones you
ever see those things what the
helicopter that has like the legs that
come out like that and it's like
hollowed the ospre or whatever no no no
it's it's they they're they're for
moving things yeah it's how they put
like uh antennas on the top of
skyscrapers and stuff yeah my we used to
my family's company used to do it down
in Philly I I would take off school and
go and look at them all the time what
the helicopters yeah if they had to get
units up on the uh sky like on the
high-rises yeah they would you would I
never told you any of this no really oh
yeah all growing up not all growing up
but at least once a year I thought you
guys just said wonky sheetrock and bad
copper yeah had some of them do
that you guys had a helicopter on
standby you hired a company yeah yeah
yeah so you get to meet the pilot no
they don't even get out they just
[__] they I remember the one guy flew
up from Kentucky made like three stops
and was going to Boston and then turning
back like no [__] so you're like we we
block off traffic like block off Market
Street or whatever the units are on the
back of a [__] truck just like un
like you know unstrapped all ready to
wait they're all [__] the helicopter
would come into the
city yeah and like come come down in the
middle of I don't know how far down but
yeah like whoa or like we was picking
him up here like where he could get
close enough and pick him up from the
street you'd hook them put those little
like anchor eyelets on dude I was
standing right there I was like shot I
was like it's dangerous yeah I remember
but I was enthralled and then pick him
up and they take him up then there's a
whole another crew up there that says
like you know they do all the hand
signals they drop it down on the I've
seen like most shocking videos where one
of those got loose sure on the [__]
uh like Hotel in La mhm just [__]
yeah caused some damage mayor was on the
phone yeah you're ruin after
City just guts to me uh yeah I loved it
I would take off school every time we
[__] every time they had one it was a
handful of them wasn't like little dirt
ball man those Pilots talk about nerves
of Steel dude I think it's just they're
so used to it you know what I mean
nerves of Steel nerves of Steel crazy
type of guy barf fight breaks out he
doesn't even look up from his beard he
finishes it oh yeah yeah no shit's nuts
um even getting in a helicopter is crazy
this is the type of guy who cries once
every 10 years but it's real gnarly when
he does it a Magnum PI get
him
that's what crack episode finally gets
you ever see the last Magnum PI it's a
tearjerker oh yeah he gets killed he
goes to heaven Magnum PI yeah they cut
to him in heaven he's in heaven most of
the last two episodes I thought maybe
like he lost one of his Hawaiian shirts
or something no oh [__] that's an odd
choice for a he gets popped in a
warehouse and he still has to solve the
the the the crime what's going on
something with his ex-wife and his buddy
from n they were all like that
really the whole
joke [__] love that show man Tom
celic was the [__] [__] you know what
caught me at the right age for the right
amount of time unironically what Walker
Texas Ranger no way oh yeah oh big time
I think my stepdad used to watch it
that's what got me going I seen a few
episodes In the Heat of the Night oh man
that Walker was all right anytime I
would flip on that that's in a category
of like Xena Warrior Princess I'm like
who watches this [__] well Zena warrior
princess she had a set of jugs on her
I'm calling balls or strikes over here
that was Saturday on Fox Saturday
afternoons on Fox you could catch that
and it was followed up by a Star Trek
Star Trek next Generation and I'm in may
catch a deep space n that lineup in the
middle of the day wasn't too shabby
Walker Texas Ranger is so good hillbilly
soap opera dude loved it Touched by an
Angel was all right too every every
fight Jane Seymour every fight scene is
him throwing a punch about 19 ft away
from a guy who then like jumps through a
window sure flies through a play Class
Window is that Kevin
Sorbo who was who was Zena Warrior
princess's
counterpart Hercules it was Kevin Sorbo
I think or that was a spin-off of
Hercules something like that I think
Hercules was a spin-off of no that can't
be Xena Warrior Princess had to be a
spin-off of Hercules
I think that was the first one to come
out she was she printing money back down
what are you talking about I know it's
uh it's a spin-off of Hercules yeah oh
really that was his main broad yeah
Hercules 134 episodes hello little bit
of G yeah back then too that's [__]
money know what you're talking about
that's all right uh all right let's see
here this one's from ru Gary V ever kick
and scream at a recliner for not closing
man that [__] [__] kills me kills me
it'll real dude cuz you're doing that
like we you're doing that like weird
thrust and you're it's very
uncomfortable and you're you're stuck
back oh I [__] hate it there's that
video going around that guy screaming
he's like kicking it and punching it and
you see it he ends up flipping it wigs
out is it a right a manual one I don't
know I used to love those pop that back
yeah feel like feel like Quick Draw
couldn't tell me nothing yeah uh we had
remember when we got them at my dad's
house man that was [__] we weren't a
recliner
family up until recently no we never my
mom we never were but I guess he came
across some of that helicopter money or
something and man he got these green
ones that were [__] you couldn't I
people used to come over I got Jack do
out we were couch people still are non
sectional couch people uh still still no
sectional at the folies yeah my mom just
has two sofas oh a love seat and a
three- seater yeah oh no we're sectional
now we're sectional people look at you
maybe 2 three years ago now that I think
about it there you go we have a recliner
now but it was left over from when my
dad was sick we might have uh a robo
recliner like raise him up so he can get
up I bet you love that I use it every
time I'm home you're standing up eating
dinner in
it um I always use it I was like stop
doing that get out of the chair you paid
for it you know it was what's really
trashy but we just did uh whatever last
month that uh Madison a massage chair
yeah oh man that thing tickles you in
all the right places that's one of those
things that you're like there's no way
these work and then you get in it and
you're like this is the best version of
this this could be they're so good I got
to get one for the crib [__] take the
edge off shake it out a then um have you
ever sat in a m in a broken massage
chair in someone's house doesn't work
anymore but you can still feel the balls
poking in the back I don't know I'm sure
at some I don't know if I ever knew
anybody that had one really my buddy had
one that did not work and that's that's
just a chair that's a chair now that's
just a real uncomfortable chair that's
exactly what that is
counterintuitive uh I did one at the
mall I remember I did one at the mall
for the first time probably when I was
like 22 years old blew my [__] hair
back oxer Valley Mall getting all in oh
yeah like I like my whoever was shopping
my mom or something I said give me a
five spot
go get me an Annie ANS I'll be here all
right let's do one more here this is
from wburg $10 Bozo uh is it garbage if
your dad took you and your brothers to
the movies every two weeks just so he
could squeeze in what he dubbed a $5 nap
first time I called him SN I called him
snoozing was during Too Fast Too
Furious man that's all right if you're
looking for a [__] 2our dark D that
don't fall asleep in the movies I never
understood that as a kid I'm like what
are you doing there's explosions now
dude you catch me a movie theater if
it's after 8:00 p.m. Kippy go night
night especially if you crush the candy
and popcorn during the previews I'm out
forget about oh [__] good night that's
one of uh nice and dark and cool in
there especially with those recliner
chairs oh man out [__] forget about
it out I want to do the one there's one
in there's a bunch of them now but
there's a new one in New York that I
drive by a bunch of uh like the
restaurant style one I don't know if
it's like you order on the card or the
phone and you lay back I want to I want
to do that oh I know you're talking
about but also I'm like I can just do
that at home I don't need [__] you
know true I'm not going to really enjoy
the movie I'm [__] I'm there for the
amenities you know what I mean SE time
Kippy go I have two tickets to sheepy
town please go to a movie getting a lay
flat I have a few bloody marriage all
right we got to wrap it up gang we love
you to death uhhuh grab those tickets
for that Town Hall Show New York City
it's going to go quick I'm telling you
right now come see the boys we love you
and we'll see you next week peace